hey guys we have some good news and some
of you might have already known about it
so for the ones who are in the dark then
here it is there has been a confirmation
for a sequel to godzilla vs kong
by legendary pitchers and i [ __ ] you not
they have even approached adam wingard
for the sequel and there
are talks to make this movie even more
awesome than the last one
legendary even tweeted hashtag continue
the most of us is trending
with a grin emoji this is big news as
they might
nene there will be a fifth entry to the
most of us and maybe this one will be
like
phase two of the franchise like kind of
like the mcu setting up things for
another major monster mashup
after all there are lots of kaiju who
haven't been seen in a 21st century big
screen
so let's discuss the 5 reasons why there
will be a sequel
let's get down with this sickness reason
number one
the hollow earth has not been explored
yet in the movie godzilla versus gone we
got glimpses of the mysterious hollow
earth
the birthplace of the titans and maybe
even humans
and although it was showcased for quite
a lengthy running time
not much is known about it aside from
the fact that gravity is inverted
and there is no sky but just two
landscapes facing down on each other
there is also the history of the kong
species that was explained in just
brief statements in the novelization
which we should get more about in the
sequel
and i hope it's about kong as he is
currently the king of the place
and we hope that there will be more apex
predators in the hollow earth
and more about finding remaining kongs
in the place which would make sense as
as kom is a social creature and but we
haven't seen
that side of him with others of his own
kind reason number two
kong is not yet named as the king the
king of skull island
the rival alpha tyrant the god of the
eerie such are the nicknames for kong
but we all know what his ultimate name
is
it's king kong and we haven't seen that
in the monster verse
so the next sequel should be about how
comb gets his famed title
and that would be the climax of his
storyline it should be calm
hollow earth or simply king kong and the
year of which the movie will be released
like king kong 1933 or king kong 2005.
titanoscope is the last of his kind and
maybe he finds a group of cons living
quietly in the hollow earth
since it is a large place and somehow he
becomes the king
reason number three godzilla's death
godzilla has been fighting quite a lot
and narrowly escaping his demise with
the muto prime king ghidorah and mecha
godzilla
just like the undertaker lost his streak
at wwe
wrestlemania so should godzilla pave way
for a future of his own kind
in the show era heisei and even the
recent animes
godzilla had to die in order to complete
the circle
in his fight with destroyer he died and
junior lift on
in the very first movie he was killed by
the oxygen destroyer only for another
godzilla to emerge from hibernation
so in the sequel if godzilla was to
appear it should be
to cement his fate after all titan's
gojira isn't immortal
there was dagon his ancestor that was
killed by the mutual prime
and in the movie we saw a huge skeleton
of an ancient gojira killed by a battle
axe of the gongs
so maybe yes if godzilla dies in the
next sequel it would complete a story
arch
reason number four it is the top
grossing movie
with over 400 million dollars in the
pandemic season
the previous installations of the
monster verse which is the king of the
monsters was made on a budget between
160 to 200 million dollars and it made a
revenue over only 383 million dollars
this is pale in comparison to 2014
godzilla that touch
529 and kong skull island with 561
million
and still there was the sequel godzilla
vs scorm which was released in a dark
time
where most theaters have been shut down
or operating with
50 or even 33 capacity and some
countries where it hasn't even been
released yet
yet even though it was made with the
same budget as kotm
it managed to beat it with more than 400
million dollars to its name
and also money from hbo max that is
currently undefined
so let's just say around 500 million
dollars so so this is a success
and obviously legendary will play out
another movie another sequel
to make some money reason number five
the ultimate evil monster is yet to be
introduced
in both the heisei series and the
millennium movies
and even in the reward era of movies
mechagodzilla is not
the last one he did not close out the
series of movies
it was always shadowed by an even
greater threat in the sequel
there was the space godzilla and then
destroyer in the 1990s and then there is
monster x
and void ghidorah in the others so as
you can see
there has to be another creature another
super titan that should close off the
monster verse
and it might happen after the next
sequel in another movie that will pitch
both
kong and godzilla against it something
that would slaughter both humans and
titans alike
and yes that will bring a fitting end a
fitting depth to the king of the
monsters
but that's just what we think hashtag
continue the monster verse
so now we come to the end of the video
of the five reasons why there will be a
sequel to godzilla vs kong
anyway it's been a blast do hit that
like button for support
and subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family and also smash that bell
button for regular updates on master
videos
right here on minecube take care fam